eSports is growing rapidly these days
with new orgs popping up all over huge
investments coming in from non-endemic
sources and some companies asking
allegedly for millions of dollars to buy
to their franchise leaves it's easy to
feel like we're in a bubble one that's
about to pop I'm not a business expert
by any means but I do know that once
upon a time eSports was in a pretty
similar position to the one it's in now
major outside investment was driving up
production costs and salaries and
changing the entire industry and then
everything collapsed but eSports rebuilt
from that mess and I think we can learn
a lot from what happened a decade ago
the CGS doesn't make it this would be
the end of the eSports so eSports look
pretty different in the early to mid
2000s there were almost no leagues no
salaries and streaming was still just a
pipe dream instead there were a handful
of grassroots events run by companies
like ESL MLG and dreamhack and they
pretty much amounted to LAN parties sure
there were prizes for the winners but
they didn't look anything like they do
today they've proved themselves all
season long and they did it again
tonight
winning $20,000 by finishing first place
congratulations there were a few big
events though for example the Cpl World
Tour had a million dollar prize pool and
finals were broadcast on MTV but it
quickly fell off
yeah you can hear it crazy down there
but the CPL got the attention of TV
executives who are looking to replicate
the success of the World Series of Poker
they wanted to turn gaming into a
spectator sport and News Corp decided to
fund their own televised gaming
tournaments this is the championship
gaming Invitational
[Applause]
after two successful pilots on DirecTV
the championship gaming series was
Greenland and became eSports first
official televised the league in 2007 on
opening night you'll get a chance to see
all six teams in action including a
rematch of last year's World Finals
between the Chicago Chimera and the
Carolina core it all starts June 2nd at
9 p.m. Eastern weeknights through June
13th at the CGS calm
CGS was a pretty big departure from
everything eSports looks like in the mid
2000 actually it looked pretty much like
what we see today with a light show and
a big stage and Brad I hope
first up Stockholm magnetic managed by
legendary GM and mil Heaton Christensen
they'll be looking to go one better in
2008 after finishing behind Berlin in
the European final and the word final in
2007 redeye wasn't the only heat sports
personality you know about that was
involved with CGS FNX Moe sponge to
flarin and Henry G all played CS in the
league at one point or another while the
stockholm magnetic and the los angeles
complexity stuck around as ninjas in
pyjamas and complexity respectively CGS
also paid people pretty well which was
rare in eSports at a time allegedly CGS
paid out five million dollars in
salaries and bonuses across the first
season with millions more invested into
production but this is the story of the
first eSports bubble popping which means
that things weren't exactly perfect for
one while there were a few endemic
eSports personalities and business
people involved the production as a
whole didn't really get eSports I mean
just watch DirecTV has flipped the
script gaming is the hottest board on
the planet and these players these
players these players are fast becoming
21st century sports heroes this video
just
[Applause]
she was a few levels higher than me when
we first met but let's just say she's
helped me gain a few experience points
experience points there was also the
game selection scene at the time halo
was the hottest eSport in na but MLG was
running all of that game as major
tournaments instead CGS had
counter-strike source dead or alive for
FIFA oh seven and Project Gotham Racing
in 2008 they upgraded to FIFA o eight
and four to two but any way you look at
it these were not the most popular
eSports in the world and for some reason
they insisted on only showing source
from a third-person perspective which is
just awful five men up for faulty teams
again some of the best games from the
San Francisco optics last year came on
this map they're certainly a capable
counter-strike team but the question is
is how much more capable could the
Birmingham salvo feast but what's most
similar to today and probably what's
most important to remember about the CGS
is that the way it interacted with the
existing eSports scene was disasterous
these days we say that eSports has just
a leftist Wild West phase but that's
only half true see the real Wild West of
eSports was the mid 2000s which was full
of unpaid prizes unpaid salaries and
look it was just a lot of people not
being paid okay CGS wasn't as shady when
it came to paying people which made them
appealing to a lot of people in the
industry unfortunately according to
eSports journalist Richard Lewis who
briefly worked for CGS back in the day
the league effectively choked competing
tournaments out of existence teams and
players in CGS couldn't attend any
tournament they wanted because CGS
executives demanded a certain level of
exclusivity now there was a very famous
case at the time there's a chap called a
Z at Kevin AZN Wang and he played in in
CGS he was a 1.6 player and he went to a
small one point six lamb for friends and
he got fined $5,000 which was a big
chunk of his salary but for attending
this lab because a didn't ask expressed
permission and B Hadi ass
suppress permission he wouldn't have got
permission because CCGs had gone with
counter-strike source and therefore you
were not allowed to play 1.6 talking
about 1.6 promote 1.6 while you're
working for the CGS not to mention the
fact that organisations who didn't want
to sell their brands to CGS were quickly
broken up as their players were offered
better salaries and what the team could
afford and this is again what the CGS
did it broke existing teams apart and it
did take a special a special form of
pleasure in doing it 2d teams that
didn't want to toe the line
fnatic for example had the best
counter-strike source team in the world
at the time and they didn't want to sell
the fnatic grant to CGS so that their
team got broke apart and weren't allowed
to compete as a 5 CGS gobbled up most of
the top-level forest players in North
America which meant that those players
weren't attending most tournaments that
meant those tournaments couldn't secure
sponsorships which meant over prize
money which meant teams didn't want to
go in the first place which meant those
tournaments eventually went away leaving
only CGS basically CGS built themselves
an enormous bubble and they primed it to
Paul but the league itself did see some
successes it got people in the
mainstream talking about eSports being
on TV was a much bigger deal in 2007
that it is now and allegedly it had a
decent rated yeah the magical number for
the Birmingham salvo was 22 the optics
on the other hand they needed 8 rounds
on the CT side and while counter-strike
miracles have happened in the
championship gaming series not tonight
the only miracle that we saw was
Birmingham salvo bringing home the world
championship
CGS was meant to be an enormous sea
change for eSports and then it all came
crashing down 2008 was kind of an
important year
Ironman kick-started the MCU bitcoin was
invented and oh yeah the global economy
fell off a cliff and into a recession we
are still feeling the effects of the
recession changing eSports a lot but
what's important for our purposes right
now is that basically single-handedly it
killed CGS before we really had the
chance to work from the inside to fix
some of the issues
and how it was presented in some of the
formats you know the global recession
yeah and they were already like fifty
million dollars deep into this thing the
economy was tanking and these court was
closing a lot of his speculative
projects and we got shut down the
company's bankrolling CGS saw the global
recession and decided to shut the show
down and to a certain extent that makes
logical sense
I mean CGS was not making money hand
over fist it was a purely speculative
venture that they hoped would make money
in the future when eSports was bigger I
mean they literally said it was an idea
whose time came too soon but by killing
it so suddenly they did a lot of damage
the eSports industry as a whole was hit
hard but individual people were hit
harder so I went from owning a law firm
and owning complexity selling both to
pursue the eSports dream to being
unemployed in a state that it wasn't
even licensed to practice law in Jayson
Lake wasn't the only person whose life
was uprooted by CGS every player
broadcast personality and
behind-the-scenes producer was left
jobless but perhaps more importantly
they were left without a lot of
prospects remember how CGS pushed an ACS
tournament out of the market well
without a circuit to return to oh one of
the source players quit on mass because
the money that was left in the scene
wasn't even close to what CGS had paid
them even wanted to quit people didn't
want to keep going to never there's a
few guys who wanted to set down some
people went back to 1.6 but there wasn't
a lot of money left in the NA eSport
scene which caused a lot of talented
players to quit the lack of money wasn't
just because CGS left a giant cash
vacuum when they disappeared a big
factor was that CGS was all of a sudden
an enormous high-profile failure one
that News Corp invested millions of
dollars into it was enough to make
anybody think twice about investing
their money into eSports it was really
really tough
I was once famously quoted when CGS was
starting out that if I said if CGS
doesn't make it now this would be the
end of the eSports or something to that
effect and I wasn't right but I wasn't
totally wrong either it's not the CGS
did a great job of presenting CGS to the
masses they didn't but the fact that
matter was that their failure earned the
quality back
investment was gone TV with a pipedream
and salaries shrank but I'm standing
here you're watching an eSports YouTube
channel we have highly paid players
franchise league's eSports on TV not
that it really matters these days more
than a decade Oh later what happened
well the few companies that survived the
crash toughed it out and helped rebuild
east force from the grassroots Dreamhack
ESL MLG they all kept doing what they
were doing sure the recession probably
impacted their bottom lines but they saw
the future that eSports could provide
then we have the CGS comes along in 2007
and we're like yeah awesome fifty
million dollars we can play with we can
make eSports mainstream we can go on TV
awesome and then the recession hits in
2008 and that kills that and it also
killed off Cpl completely by then it
also killed off W SVG which was the
replacement WCG was continuing to
decline in terms of numbers east of DC
wasn't wasn't going the same way so then
we have another dam and then we have to
wait until 2011 before we start to see
real shoots of improvement most of it
coming out of career most of it coming
from Starcraft most to be coming from
Twitch hilariously the same year that
CGS launched 2007 was the year that
justin.tv started broadcasting justin.tv
found a ton of popularity with live
gaming streams which they spun off into
twitch which eventually became one of
the most important catalyst for the
eSports Renaissance were in today
that chuan trying to survive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ten years ago eSports had a TV show big
salaries and mainstream media attention
today we have all that and more
we might be staring down another bubble
again but this time eSports knows what
it takes to survive the bubble popping
doesn't mean that eSports are gonna
suddenly go away it means that things
will have to scale back and the people
who survived the crash know how to do
that they know how to scale back and
keep eSports chugging along they know
that no matter how much investor money
is poured into the scene no matter how
much of it suddenly disappears one day
people will always want to play video
games together they know what to do if
the bubble pops to embrace the grassroot
communities that make eSports so special
so much you can hear the crowd
everyone's cheering the team when you
make friends these people you talk to
you play with online it's all about
communities being part of something that
you're incredibly passionate about
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]